el pedido de vacancia según pasaron los
días buen terreno esfuerzo de ser unos
audios bastantes escandalosos donde
hayan una investigación fiscal del por
medio de la estrategia del ejecutivo con
todo básicamente en general la duda en
los en el congreso en donde se requerían
87 votos para poderlo destituir sin
embargo como generó duda del congreso no
sabemos el modo se pudo bajar al
presidente pero si de alguna manera
queda bastante mediada la figura del
ejecutivo pero también de legislativo no
porque se ha visto de que había un
enfrentamiento de poderes en un momento
de catástrofe como el de esta pandemia
no considera usted que efectivamente
había elementos para destituir a
vizcarra
evidentemente no porque si bien es
cierto la figura de la incapacidad moral
está vigente en nuestra constitución acá
en el perú desde 1839 y se ha aplicado
en cuatro casos específicos últimamente
en el año 2017 durante el gobierno de
pedro pablo kuczynski se tuvo que
aplicar yo creo que hubo un criterio de
valoración o ponderación respecto a la
gravedad de los hechos y es que
realmente había una dignidad tal que ha
sido inviable de que el actual
presidente de vizcarra pueda seguir
ejerciendo el cargo del presidente del
congreso no no lo valoro bashir a pesar
de que nuestra constitución es una
figura de tipo abierto es decir el
juicio de valor el criterio que tiene
congresista es autónomo con respecto a
este juicio político
víctor quijada muchísimas gracias por su
presencia